(suspenseful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(drilling)
(suspenseful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(sirens blaring)
(metal clanging)
(speaking in foreign language)
(anticipatory music)
(beeping)
(speaking in foreign language)
(intense music)
- Hey, I'm Steve.
(speaking in foreign language)
(glasses clinking)
(tires screeching)
(intense music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Let's go.
(laughing)
(intense music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(sirens blaring)
(intense music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(clapping)
- Fire!
(guns shooting)
(intense music)
(laughing)
(speaking in foreign language)
(intense music)
(woman screaming underwater)
(gun shooting)
(speaking in foreign language)
(sirens blaring)
(clock ticking)